all right everybody let's jump into this
first story
uh you know we were originally gonna
lead with the big political story but
then i was like no way we gotta talk
about this leaked audio this is crazy
from the daily mail exclusive quote i
think you're clear
yeah what does that mean
voicemail from joe biden to hunter about
new york times report on his chinese
business dealings proves he did speak to
his son about his relationship with
criminal dubbed the spy chief of china
yo man
i just i i'm not surprised and i kind of
don't i can it get any worse for joe
biden his legacy his son
when this comes out and it's like oh
here's audio of joe biden himself
talking to his kid about his business
it's a voicemail i'm just not surprised
and i don't know if you can move the
needle from like zero to less than zero
in terms of like
faith in this man as president but let's
let's read a little bit more i'm i'm i'm
um
fumbling around the mouse because my my
wrist is probably broken so uh you'll
have to bear with me as i'm trying to
navigate this this episode is brought to
you by family mouse that's right yeah
that's right that's our sponsor all
right president joe biden spoke with
hunter about his business dealings with
a chinese criminal and his son dubbed
the spy chief of china a voicemail to
his son reveals so i'll put it this way
we'll play it in a second
either this was the extent that joe
talked to hunter he sent him a voicemail
and said i think you're clear and that
was it
presumably leaving a voicemail means you
intend to talk to them in greater detail
so it sounds like this is evidence he
did at least try to talk to his son and
brought up the issue and told him he
wasn't clear i think it's circumstantial
evidence they probably had a longer
conversation about let me play this
audio for you right now
hey palace dad it's 8 15. um
a chance give me a call nothing urgent
i just want to talk to you i thought the
article at least the thing on online
that's going to be printed one of the
times is good
i make you clear
and
anyway um
if you get a chance give me a call
and that's it so yeah scrolling away
because the next auto play is hunter
naked and i don't want to play that oh
wow i mean
shocking revelation that joe biden does
know what day of the week it is yeah i
know i was surprised well that's a
four-year-old phone call i believe sorry
oh man okay all right okay i got a
couple issues they frame this as it's
proof they say proof in the in the
article title which it's evidence like
you said circumstantial proof well it
could have been doctored which doesn't
sound like it was could have been
doctored no and also there's no context
what is he even talking about you're in
the clear what's he talking about i
don't know if i read this so so i'll put
it this way perhaps um i would be
willing to entertain the daily mail is
completely lying to us about this but
the daily mail has the laptop they've
they've been going through it the emails
have been verified at the very least the
new york times has confirmed this
it's a question of do you trust your
source well newsguard says the daily
mail is certified as not publishing
false news
and what more can i say if they say that
they got this audio they know the time
stamp on it they know when this article
came out what it was about
i think they've done their work and
they've made the assessment now you can
choose not to believe it that's fine
some people sometimes news outlets lie
and quite frequently in fact i think
this is more likely than not absolutely
true especially considering we already
know that that joe biden lied about this
joe biden was talking you know asked
like do you you know hunter biden the
business dealings and he's like i don't
talk about any of this stuff and then
photos emerged of joe with hunter and
his associates
playing golf or something it's like come
on dude we know you're lying come on man
come on man that's right how did daily
mail make the association here that he
was talking about
these chinese associates when he said
you're in the clear from like how do
they make the extrapolation from the
voicemail joe called hunter on december
12th 2018 saying that he wanted to talk
to him about uh talk to him after
reading a new york times story about
hunter's dealings the chinese oil giant
perhaps there's more to the call or more
calls they didn't release perhaps they
simply know the time stamp happened
right when a big story specifically the
article yeah he didn't mention an
article yeah he said it in the in the
text yeah yeah like like joe actually
said
just give me a call nothing urgent just
want to talk uh talk to you
he says i read the article released
online it's gonna be printed tomorrow
a15 you know
okay yeah yeah so no i think i think ian
brings up a good point you know but but
i'm just gonna say i i'm i believe the
daily mail uh did their due diligence
and they they have this stuff from the
laptop we know the laptop's real is it
true that joe biden flew hunter to china
on air force two yes so okay for him to
be flying his son to china around the
world putting him on the board of
barisma this energy company in ukraine
well i don't wanna say joe i didn't put
him on that okay maybe he didn't but to
say that that this is hap that he's on
the board that he's been flown to china
i mean he's fluent in china but that
he's not involved with his business
somehow is insane i mean that's that's
that's involvement if you're flying the
guy there well they shared a bank
account mm-hmm is this confirmed
tim said it multiple times on air i know
that we um we have this phone call which
is great but it just seems to me at this
point we should
be able to have an investigation there
should have been an investigation before
this came out there will be when he's
not president you think so i don't know
if people wanted the political
persecution or if we just should do it
regardless of political persecution
ideals like it just needs to be
investigated because of sitting
president
my first thought was what what you said
you know a little bit skeptical but i'm
i'm still reeling from the fact that i
think that audio is doctored because
that's that's joe biden stringing
together quite a quick coherent sentence
right
um without anything that's good evidence
it's not real not real yeah right if the
daily mail was really trying to
fabricate they needed to make him say
come on man a couple times
maybe some gibberish words are for your
brush
word salad yeah and then i'd believe it
no but it's four years ago
so you know he's only gotten worse since
then
and um
you know the thing about joe is that he
when you get old like him you can
probably handle a few hours a day but
it's what is it called sundowning or
sunsetting yeah yeah yep sundowning yes
like you're awake for a few hours you're
spry and then within a couple hours
you're just
ready for
that happens to me now yeah oh wow i'm
sorry sheamus maybe you need more
vitamin b maybe yeah b12 b6 maybe well
maybe the healthy aging support of
calorin there you go that's for sure
wait someone tell me more about that
that's right it's wonderful thanks for
watching the show everyone
flavorless yeah yeah that's really good
i have some in my coffee right now by
the way my dad's been taking collagen
and apparently it's extremely good for
your skin
he's had skin reparations in his older
and he's like he's 70 and he's like man
my cuts are healing better now dude it's
great look at this from nbc news they
say at the time it seemed mildly
noteworthy but not particularly unusual
then vice president joe biden traveling
to china on an official visit bringing
his son on air force two
so it's like
know
this family is corrupt and we've known
this yeah i know that's why that's why i
almost didn't want to lead with this
story and i was like
you know oh yeah more more leaks about
joe biden being dirty
and shocking what's next what happens if
there is more evidence comes out i mean
what would you all want to happen oh he
should be impeached out right 100 so we
had um
troy nails on congressman from texas and
i asked him i was like this might be a
hard question but should the republicans
win in november will you impeach joe
biden without miss skipping a beat he's
like yes of course absolutely
joe biden has done so much that the very
least
is circumstantial evidence war or
probable cause warning a very serious
investigation i think what we know about
what what joe biden's done is completely
impeachable and if not i mean criminal
so you know we saw the uh the democrats
come out and say that donald trump
engaged in a quid pro quo with ukraine
was it with yeah i was with ukraine to
try and dig up dirt on joe biden
the reality of the story is that donald
trump uncovered joe biden engaging in a
quid pro quo with ukraine to fire a
prosecutor who happened to have been
investigating the company where joe
biden's son was working
i'm not saying he did it because his son
was working there but those things are
all facts that alone is like joe biden
should be impeached he's on video saying
he did it he's laughing about it but he
didn't do it while he was president so
can you impeach a president for
something they did before they were
president he was vice president yes well
i mean he's lying about it absolutely
absolutely
he should be investigated for it the the
assumption is that and now he's giving
how many billions of dollars to ukraine
so i mean that's just right there the
united states being like oh we gotta
give 70 billion dollars to ukraine oh
geez i wonder why maybe it's because
it's payback now where the president's
son was on the board of an energy
company and the president's sending
money to the comp to the country this is
so crazy it's it's just remarkable that
we know these things to be true but this
country is so full of vapid angry
ignorant and arrogant people that we are
stuck here with him as president
what do you do
he's going to tell us to go back to the
crown is what he's doing
i say i challenge you to a jewel you
people
you people
all you sorts of people i don't know who
you are um no i think you know from the
moment i mean i followed the primaries
and and it was clear to me that that joe
biden didn't stand a chance and it was
the dnc i mean they picked him you know
he was i think he was fourth place in
carolina so you know and then you know
to pick camilla as the vice president
and to pick her because she's quote a
black woman it's like well why don't you
just pick the best person and even if it
happens to be a woman who happens to be
black just let that just be there and
she can take some delight in but we you
know same with the supreme court nominee
uh it just it's all i don't know i'm
english it's it's devoid of of principle
yeah of course logic well so biden had
promised if i'm not mistaken that he was
going to select a woman of color to be
his vice president that was the debate
with bernie wasn't it yeah and part of
what's so hilarious about that is he
obviously did it to pander to
progressives but i don't know a
progressive who can stand kamala harris
i know i don't know anyone that's ever
told her
exactly i i met a lady and she was like
i love kamala and i was like why you're
the only person it's her laugh isn't it
it's so endearing it's very very
contagious
it's like hillary was bad and then
kamala comes along what's up with that
they're like it's because you hate women
that's what's up right now what is
the hillary thing was well the obama
thing was there was identity politics
about him being like the first black
president i think and he was like you
know half black half white whatever but
then the the identity politics really
started grinding with hillary clinton
when they were like i'm with her it was
all about her i mean not that you could
say i'm with him i'm with him but you
wouldn't know which him you're talking
about
maybe it was just but it seemed very
much like it's her time it's her time
and it wasn't like it's her time it's
her time it's about the fact that which
is such an embarrassing thing to say
like like mom said i can play video
games now like it's her time like it's
her turn this is something she's just in
line for it's funny because like with
the roe v wade decision getting
overturned i was just like you know this
is hillary clinton's fault right
like
so uh you know the the old parable of
this this frog and the scorpion
there's a funny meme i posted where it's
like the frog says but now we will
surely both drown in the scorpion says
lol lmao thought it was hilarious
because like but it's basically you know
the frog i kicked him i'm wrong but you
know you know the story the frog is like
vaguely there's a river and the
scorpion's like help me across the river
the frog's like no you'll sting me and
he's like nah i won't because then we'll
both die and then the scorpion jumps on
the frog's like okay good point scorpion
jumps on his back they start swimming
the scorpion stings them and the frog's
like but now we'll both die and it says
yes but it isn't my nature
something like that right so like
donald trump
got three conservative supreme court
justices that is exactly what you would
expect the republicans to do if they won
we knew that's what they wanted to do
they said they wanted to do it so how do
you prevent that
well
hillary clinton was how you make it
happen people despise that woman and so
when bernie sanders was rising in
popularity the democrats were like
better to nuke everything about our
platform
because it's hillary's turn and bernie's
bad
than to allow you know than then to to
allow bernie to win imagine being
hillary clinton and you couldn't beat
donald trump and then you see joe biden
do it
man
that's gotta hurt her especially with
him not campaigning yeah yeah like
literally hiding in a basement what did
trump call him joe haydn
beautiful that's great yeah he was
learning his lines right so the people
the vp
traditionally right
runs for president can you see that
happening with them with uh
oh yeah
you're right
it's kind of interesting
but it isn't she would also go
yes
but you mentioned that that the vp
usually runs for president isn't it
interesting that joe didn't after the
obama administration they said it was
because his son died
okay that's understandable but uh they
didn't want bernie to win because that
was like an insurgency
but you know if hillary if if ruth bader
ginsburg retired this wouldn't happen
roberts uh would have been on the side
of keeping roe v wade
she could have retired
obama could have appointed a liberal
justice
maybe i mean you know some a lot of
people said that i'm kind of like yeah
maybe not because mcconnell still
blocked garland anyway so there's if i
don't think obama could have got anybody
in if maybe if she retired
very early on
but the issue is simple
if hillary did not run
trump would not have won
like if
i won but but not even bernie like
anyone else
it's like trump
won by i think 88 000 votes across three
states which gave him a big electoral
college lead
hillary clinton it was her turn she
wanted it everybody should be yelling at
her
or dnc i'm still getting over the fact
that the man who was on a reality show
when you're fired every week became i
mean did that that really happened and
here we are now with this teleprompter
president
who who really you know i've said for
some time he looks like he's just not
cognitively all there he doesn't just
look like it he acts like it yeah yeah
and he talks like it and if it lock if
it talks like a duck walks like a duck
but you gotta duck yeah yeah no it's
true quack quack if the president speaks
like he's mentally impaired walks like
he's mentally impaired and has an
expression on his face like he's
mentally impaired we're in a lot of
trouble
this isn't a partisan thing either this
isn't like you know the
like
i would think that it is
well it is but it shouldn't be i mean
it's just a rational reasonable you look
at this either it's an intravenous drip
of vodka from seven in the morning or or
there's something cognitively in decline
with his brain and i don't say that in a
mean-spirited way but he literally can't
string a sentence together with a and
then occasionally the the rashes of
temper i mean when he was on the
campaign trail there was that worker on
the ship on the factory floor who was
just asking him about i think it was
assault weapons
and he was like in his face and losing
if there was just a you know what it is
it's when people have uh
like dementia that's right or
alzheimer's
rage can occur because
their brain isn't giving them access to
the information they need and it's very
frustrating it's very frustrating to
have someone say something
to know you know the answer but be
unable to put together so you just start
very quickly
i'm just angry like i can't do this yeah
do you think those around him are like
close and is in a circle are aware and
know something that we don't about a
medical diagnosis or or they just think
oh he's just older and a bit doddery oh
come on they know more than me i don't
know yeah yeah like
i i think there may be a diagnosis i
don't know
but it's not a secret everybody knows
this guy's brain is completely fried
and he's the president of the united
states of america he should be relieved
of command his his surrender in
afghanistan was the it was the largest
military blunder in american history i
think probably wait it lost
honestly
there's a there's a lot of mistakes we
made in the united states but i kind of
agree
abandoning bagram air force base in the
middle of the night without informing
the afghan security forces and letting
it get looted by the citizens is just
like beyond how does that happen how
does that happen with all of the chain
of command i mean the generals along the
way is someone going to speak up and
well there's two there's two ideas one
is the more conspiratorial they did it
on purpose
but then you need a bunch of evidence
i think the simple the simple answer is
joe biden's sitting in the situation
room
and his eyes are half closed he's gone
and then everyone's sitting around them
and they're all looking at each other
like do i do something you heard him
read like
no no they're just like
should i should i do something what do i
do no no you didn't say it i don't know
what to do let's just get out of here
and they get up and walk out they're
like i have no idea
no idea what to do
and so they just it's just chaos
it's also possible that joe biden says
you know we know that he was speaking to
i think the g7 and he kept saying libya
instead of syria
it's possible he was saying he meant to
say you got to evacuate the civilian
airport and he said military airport
because his brain doesn't work and they
went okay
for all we know he was like you gotta
you know we gotta get people out of
there you gotta uh you gotta
evacuate the uh airport uh
civilians you know but wouldn't someone
push back and say mr president we can't
i mean that that happens doesn't it
maybe
but maybe i i got to be honest i can
imagine joe biden saying something we've
seen him speak imagine his situation
room what do we do sir
use the airport you got to evacuate you
got to get them out you know the
civilians and then they're like the
civilian airport get them out get them
on like okay i think you're being kind i
i think he made a bad military command
he he thought that because we said i'm
saying his brain screwed up because we
said we were gonna be out by a certain
date he was like virtue signaling okay
we said we were gonna do it let's follow
through even if a hundred thousand
people die with their heads cut off uh
let's do what we said we're gonna dude
it's wartime you lie in war you do what
you need to do to get these people safe
and
this guy
is not capable
i'm just saying i think like you've got
two airports
the military
and the civilian
and he very easily could have said the
wrong word
and then he gets angry and so when
someone said sir do you mean to evacuate
the bagram just do it come on man and
they're like okay okay
whatever and then the military leaders
we've seen the joint chiefs they're woke
and stupid so they're probably just like
i i'm willing to bet
we have phil the government is full of
careerists who are just like i am not
going to stick my neck out i'm going to
give my few years that i have to do to
get the medals and then i'm out whatever
biden says is on him not me just do it
no point getting fired
right you got a crackpot as the
president he'll just go what are you
doing you're fired and it's like okay
people i'm not i'm not doing it just do
what he says people gotta listen to tim
kennedy talk to rogan about this because
tim went to afghanistan with like uh
worked with i think it was the us
department of defense or he worked with
the government to pull pull people out
after the bedlam began of the surrender
and the madness and the media showed us
like the plane's coming in the planes
going out you see people falling out of
the planes that are trying to hang on
for their life but what it didn't show
is the surrounding area outside of the
airport where people were getting cut up
where women were trying to get their
babies inside and they couldn't so they
were throwing them over what was barbed
wire
it it's and it was happening in mass for
weeks he was there for two weeks 10 days
and he said he just kept getting worse
the longer he was there and then he left
maybe maybe the issue is this
you know does it really matter why it
happened but it happened and it's joe
biden's leadership that has failed us
and there's no reason to try and make
excuses for why it happened other than
to say this guy's got to go
he's got to be impeached convicted
yeah some people are alive but then you
get kamala and i'm like i don't know is
ruthless better or worse than deranged
it's better better way better
i feel i feel like it's this way uh
kamala harris may gut and loot the
system for her personal benefit but the
system has to exist for her for her to
benefit from it joe biden's
deranged his son's a crackhead
and it's like well he could burn the
whole place down playing with matches so
it's like two years of the crazy lady
who's gonna loot the coffers for herself
at least she needs the coffers to still
exist yeah i mean i don't know i just
want everyone to consider the fact that
this is someone who given their mental
state should not be trusted with a
butter knife
and that's true he has access to the
button
he killed so much he's serious he's
given like a plastic circle to butter
his bread like when he's doing arts and
crafts i hope they give him kids
scissors i hope he has like the plastic
ones and you know he's doing arts and
crafts would be a great cartoon where
he's like dunking scissors won't cut
paper
and they're like joe you know you can't
have metal scissors
come on thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you